mériadec raffray journaliste spécialiste
du mali hauteur de touareg la révolte
des hommes bleus aux éditions economica
bonsoir mériadec raffray merci d'être
avec nous le président le premier
ministre de transition maliens qui ont
démissionné donc on a appris aujourd'hui
clairement est-ce que ça signe l'arrêt
de la transition politique
bonjour c'est fini écoutez le nom c'est
on s est beaucoup trop tôt pour le dire
d'ailleurs
dans un communiqué le l'homme qui est à
la manoeuvre c'est à dire le colonel
goïta qui est officiellement le vice
présidente 7 de cette formation de
transition et qui est le l'homme fort
qui avait débarqué ibrahim boubacar
kéïta l'année dernière en août 2020 a
dit que le processus se poursuivrait que
les élections auraient lieu à l'automne
c'est évidemment un message pour
rassurer la communauté internationale et
en particulier la france
les chaussons d'eau quand même un peu
compliqué à bamako ce que l'on comprend
aujourd'hui c'est que ce les hommes
forts de la gouvernance ceux qui
gouvernent mali ce sont toujours les
militaires et ils ont voulu le montrer
par ce nouveau coup d'état dans le coup
d'état comme comme l'appelle emmanuel
macron qui l'a condamné hier avec jean
yves le drian
en réalité on a assisté encore à una
nouvel accroc dans la gouvernance
malienne c'est quand même tout de même
relativement inquiétant ça a commencé à
peu près mi mai par le gouvernement a
été déchiqueté mis le gouvernement de
transition et enfin en fait ça s'est
noué le 24 c'est à dire lundi si je dis
pas de bêtises en tout début de semaine
puisque en réalité le collègue aux états
a refusé la nouvelle affiche qui était
proposée pour des raisons diverses et
variées le devront rentrer dans le
détail pour juste expliquer pourquoi les
choses se sont envenimées c'est que le
gouvernement avait mis de côté d'eux des
colonels
de la junte militaire l'un qui dirigeait
le mystère de défense look le mystère de
la sécurité évidemment c'était un signal
négatif envoyé aux colonels et il avait
l'air de dire que les politiques
allaient reprendre en quelque sorte une
certaine forme d'autonomie vis-à-vis des
militaires il ya aussi on dit aussi que
les gens de l'opposition de m5 ce qu'ils
avaient comment dirais-je à manifester
dans les rues
juste avant le coup d'état de l'été
dernier n'était pas représenté dans le
gouvernement puis après il ya les
problèmes de corruption etc
donc tout ça c'est un peu à un peu
entremêlés il ya deux ex deux théories
qui circulent aujourd'hui l'une disant
que dix ans lille une disant qu'en fait
alors je sais plus ce que je me dis ah
mais vous allez me relancer alors on va
te parler cher mériadec raffray des
réactions parce qu'il y en a eu beaucoup
et une à l'instant à le conseil de
sécurité de l'onu condamne l'éviction
des autorités de transition on a vu que
tout au long de ces dernières heures il
y avait des appels à la libération l'onu
la france vous l'avez dit ça veut dire
quoi que la marge de manoeuvre de la
communauté internationale elle est très
faible en réalité ça se contentent
d'aucune d'années est exactement alors
la marge de la marche mais lors de la
commutation en particulier l'onu est
très faible ce qui peuvent avoir eu un a
une incidence ou en tout cas une
influence sur ce qui se passe c'est
évidemment la france mais on voit que la
france est à nouveau décalée puisque la
france a beau jeu de condamner ce coup
d'état dans le coup d'état pour
l'expression des mêmes macron alors
qu'il y a environ un mois emmanuel
macron personnes étaient à n'djamena au
tchad pour comment dirais-je adoubé le
fils du président et disent débit le
général kaka général de 37 ans pour
prendre la succession de son père donc
d'un côté à n'djamena banal macrobe ni
un coup d'état un coup d'état pour
reprendre son expression à nouveau et
puis de l'autre côté à mois plus tard la
france 17 inacceptable envoyée il ya
quand même un sujet et ça ça pose un
vrai problème vis-à-vis de l'opinion
politique malienne la france se met à
nouveau comment dirais je
difficulté vis-à-vis de la légitimité du
pouvoir est telle qu'elle est on peut en
discuter mais bon c'est une c'est un
fait il ya eu plusieurs alertes
concernant la position politique
française au mali ces dernières mois
cette dernière année de en début d'année
il ya eu la sphère bounty la première
fois que l'armée française a été accusée
de dommages collatéraux par une partie
de la presse malienne
voilà donc à les rumeurs également
antilles françaises
ceux qui peuvent peser aussi sur les sur
ce qui se passe ce sont également les
américains ils viennent de dire ils
viennent de déclarer officiellement
qu'ils allaient suspendre leur aide
militaire à l'armée malienne alors
effectivement les américains sondés des
gros financeur en fait de l'opération
barkan et évidemment désarmé africaine
via des fonds et c'est donc ils ont un
pouvoir de manoeuvre ceci dit je ne vois
pas très bien les états unis aller
beaucoup plus loin
on va voir ce qui va se passer dans les
jours qui viennent si le pouvoir de
bamako laisse quand dirais-je donne à
nouveau des signes de normalisation de
la situation
ce qui pour l'instant paraît être
l'hypothèse la plus probable il faut
resté toutefois prudent
donc on attend pas grand chance du
conseil de sécurité de l'onu qui va se
réunir un bon jour dont je pense pas
vous restez avec nous s'il vous plaît
mériadec raffray puisqu'on va aborder un
autre sujet on reste en afrique puisque
emmanuel macron est attendu au rwanda ce
jeudi c'est le premier déplacement d'un
président français dans le pays depuis
2010 une visite très attendue aux
multiples enjeux comme nous l'expliquent
robin pu l 27 ans après le génocide
emmanuel macron souhaite normaliser les
relations entre paris et kigali
des échanges entre les deux pays sont
empoisonnées depuis près de trois
décennies par le rôle de la france dont
le massacre des tutsis survenu en 1994
la publication du rapport du clair en
mars dernier dénonçant la responsabilité
accablante du gouvernement français de
l'époque a permis de relancer le
dialogue entre l'elysée et le pays
dirigé par paul kagamé l'enjeu
mémorielle sera donc au coeur de la vie
id emmanuel macron alors que le rwanda
attend toujours des excuses de paris
le président s'adressera aux victimes de
génocide mais aussi aux rescapés
nous espérons trouver les mots justes
pour pouvoir parler à ces personnes
notre sentiment c'est que du côté de la
jeunesse africaine et de la jeunesse
française
il y as besoin de mettre des mots sur le
rôle exact de la france durant cette
période
nous allons répondre à cette demande de
compréhension mais ce déplacement revêt
aussi en enjeu économique
le président sera accompagné d'une
dizaine de chefs d'entreprises et par
les responsables de l'agencé française
du développement l'afd qui a relancé son
action au rwanda en 2019
au total près de 120 millions d'euros
ont été engagés entre autres dans la
santé l'énergie et l'enseignement ces
deux dernières années un réchauffement à
travers le prisme économique amorcée dès
2018 lors d'une rencontre entre les
actuels chefs d'état des deux pays
ils se sont mis d'accord pour travailler
sur des sujets qu'on crée d'intérêt
comme entre les deux pays
un certain nombre d'engagements ont été
pris à cette occasion qui ont
progressivement été mis en place depuis
l'arrivée d'un nouveau chargé d'affaires
à kigali le rwanda a eu des performances
remarquables ces dernières années et
peut être considérée comme une
plateforme potentiel de rayonnement
économique dans la région
lors de ce voyage les deux présidents
pourraient s'entendre sur le retour d'un
ambassadeur français à kigali où le
poste est vacant depuis 2015
l'occasion pour emmanuel macron de
concrétiser le retour de l'hexagone dans
une région considérée comme l'une des
plus dynamiques du continent africain et
on retrouve mériadec raffray pour parler
de cette visite emmanuel macron au
rwanda présenté comme un acte fort le
signe d'une mémoire pacifié d'une
relation renouer ça c'est ce que nous
dit le porte parole du gouvernement qui
affirme qu'il aura à coeur d'écrire une
nouvelle page entre la france et le
rwanda ce qui peut clairement atteindre
cet objectif avant vous égouttez gros
comme d'ailleurs nicolas sarkozy
d'ailleurs il marche sur les traces de
nico
sarkozy au rwanda force veut absolument
forcé comme on y réagit la porte
d'entrée du rwanda qui était resté qui
était restée fermée à la france depuis
les dramatiques événements des années
94 c'est à dire le génocide rwandais
pour une raison qui tient à la fois je
pense de l'idéologie et du business il
ya un mélange assez flou deux raisons
les les analystes sont assez dubitatif
on sait que nicolas sarkozy a à nouveau
repris du service pour comment dirais-je
pour le business franco-rwandais
puisqu'il travaille de manière
officielle aujourd'hui pour le groupe
accor notamment qui quittent intéressait
pour construire des hôtels
voilà donc tous athées est une est une
comment dirais-je éteindre un driver de
la politique française au rwanda qui se
fait donc sa force âge de porcs qui se
fait au prix comment dire est une quasi
réécriture de l'histoire c'est le
rapport du clerc peut dire peut dire que
la france était coupable rwanda en
réalité ce rapport a été signé par des
historiens qui sont clairement qu'ils
ont clairement un parti pris idéologique
il suffit simplement de ré écouter ce
que dit régulièrement dans les médias
que quelqu'un comme hubert védrine par
exemple qui est qui n'est pas suspect de
déviance politique est clairement ces
gens là savent très bien que la france
est intervenue au rwanda pour tenter de
mettre de mettre fin de séparer les
belligérants et surtout de mettre à
l'abri les populations fils et civiles
de ce massacre épouvantable rwandais
voilà dans une situation compliquée et
je rappelle qu'à l'époque la france
était la seule à intervenir les états
unis tous ceux qui aujourd'hui critique
facilement la position française se sont
bien gardé d'intervenir à l'époque
c'était je crois si j'étais pas de
bêtises madeleine albright qui étaient à
la peine donc voilà donc à quel prix
doit alors faire du business avec le
rwanda j'en profite au passage pour
souligner le fait que kagame est en
général est aujourd'hui ne passe pas
pour un véritable grand démocrate au
sein de son pays
l'opposition enfin les paroles
d'opposition sont quand même
assez peu bienvenus un certain nombre de
morts sont chemine le choc chemine dans
la foule autour du pouvoir et donc
kagame a sans doute une vie une image
dans les médias qui est très très
tendance est effectivement parle du pays
aux mille collines qui aujourd'hui est à
la pointe du business en particulier
dans le numérique ça c'est pour les
médias occidentaux la réalité c'est que
ceux qui connaissent et qui suivent
khayame savent que c'est un général
dictateur et je mets des guillemets sur
ces mots voilà encore une
comment dirais-je un paradoxe de la
politique africaine de la france qui va
au rwanda auprès de de ce2 du général
kagame mais qui se précipitent dans les
événements du mali pour condamner des
des officiers qui peut être sont eux
légitime aux yeux de l'opinion publique
merci en tout cas beaucoup manier dakar
après d'avoir été avec nous sur rt
france au soir pour évoquer la situation
au mali et cette visite d' emmanuel
macron auront anbar ce sera donc demain
merci à vous